that's a lot of subs but it didn't feel
quite right to make a video on just that
so I figured let's do one last round of
Secrets post number one when Gayle
teleports in phase two you might have
noticed a tiny visual detail he's
actually summoning himself with a white
summoned soapstone underneath you if
you're looking for a law explanation the
white summoned soapstone item has always
referenced a convolution of time and
it's always referenced the link between
Undead and Gale is a character that can
be summoned by you all throughout the
DLCs so it does make some sense that he
could abuse this link to your character
Gale actually has quite a few little
visual details that really flesh out his
character for instance his soapstone
messages look unlike any other and they
emanate those same skull fumes that he
has throughout all of phase two of his
boss fight so what are those skulls well
there's nothing in Dark Souls 3 that
defines them but they are pretty much
the same as those summoned by the
executioner's gloves in blood-borne
which gives us some idea of what they
were thinking with this asset in
blood-borne they are said to be the
wrathful spirits of the past and
considering they also bulge outwards
from the purging Monument I think it's
fair to say that Gale who has probably
consumed half the souls of the world by
this point it's fair to say that he is
overflowing with the spirits and the
curses of the past as well
another thing deep within Gale if you
look really closely at his character
model is a perfect circle that looks
identical to the dark sigil which is the
mark that resembles the brand of the
undead and if you a hollow devoid of
humanity did you know that you will no
long cast a shadow upon the ground or a
reflection in the water I think we can
explain why this happens in the black
flame island descriptions the and I
quote impenetrable flame of humanity is
said to be a weighty physical force so
it makes some sense that losing your
soul or your humanity would make a
hollow more ethereal and thus they would
be incapable of blocking out light and
producing a shadow but I'll admit being
shadowless is somewhat of a strange
addition especially considering it's
never directly mentioned and out of all
the souls claims this I believe only
occurs in Dark Souls 3 but I can't
really imagine them putting this in by
mistake can you another thing I'm always
unsure of is this interaction with the
fire keeper so it occurs when you return
here still drenched in the wax of the
Grand Archives she turns away
presumably in distaste for she does
exactly the same thing when you wear one
of the rings that mark you as someone
from LAN door and as we all know the
hollows of LAN door were widely tested
so assumedly she's turning away in
distaste here as well and assuming this
isn't a mistake why why would she turn
away from a wax headed scholar the only
theory I have is this to a degree filing
shrine functions as an extension of
logic a kingdom devoted to the linking
of the fire which is a goal that's
upheld by the three pillars the knight
the priestess and the scholar and of the
three there is evidence that the
scholars started to go against the
Knights and the priestesses and Lorex
fire linking legacy in general for
example the first of the scholars is
said to have doubted the linking of the
fire
and the blessed weapon enchantment was
created after the scholars acquired the
grand archives which apparently marked
the strengthening of ties between the
other two pillars the Knights and the
handmaidens so it's quite possible that
the scholars were the third pillar that
was sort of responsible for the fall of
the entire structure so to speak and
it's quite possible that this small
seemingly insignificant interaction
where she turns away in disgust could be
a third little nod towards the treachery
of scholars as well but that's just a
theory and it's one of those things
where it's really hard to know whether a
detail is meant to be important from a
logs negative and the same is definitely
true when it comes to the pictures in
the official design works take for
example this image of Fillion or where
she holds the egg except the inside of
this egg is overlaid with the stitched
crystal lizard hide of a transposing
kiln look how similar these two are so
the transposing kiln that we find within
the curse rotted great wood is said to
hail from Courland and it's stitched or
crystal is it hired and is capable of
extracting the essence of a soul and of
course the egg in game doesn't actually
have this stitched crystal lizard hired
transposing kiln within it but still
even though this was changed the picture
still gives us this rare piece of
insight into what the developers might
have actually been thinking when they
designed Fillion or it tells us that at
some stage Fillion or may have been
linked with Courland
and that at some stage the transposing
kiln here may have been the method by
which the original Dark Soul was hidden
within the ringed City also notable in
the design works is a fourth shrine of
Ferren that doesn't appear alongside the
three others in ferrand swamp the three
existing shrines depict the four kings
nato
and the witch of izalith and this four
removed shrine depict seif the pale
drake the last three things i want to
talk about a few speedrunning tricks
first the fast wyvern kill basically you
run to the elevated part of the stairs
you hope for the horizontal fire breath
and then you perform a jump attack with
the right timing then the fight is over
next a jump skipped to skip aerosol and
this one is best performed with a
keyboard so that you can get some better
90-degree angle changes by nestling your
character in this corner you align the
camera just like this then you sprint
into the corner and then abruptly run
forward and jump at the second step down
from here if this short glitchy walk to
a distant mana bonfire which gets
basically all of aerosol to get to your
and finally a little trick that
completely immobilizes the watches of
Faron walk into this corner then align
your base vigor health bar just so it's
at the edge near this candle then tap
forward on your keyboard commit to a
fully charged r2 then a single R to skip
the cutscene quit out get back in and
the fight is yours so I'm not going to
go into great detail on these because
honestly if these stripes have piqued
your interest in any way then you can
find them all on the speed souls wiki or
you really should watch them all
performed firsthand by the speedrunning
community this game has on twitch
because if you haven't yet delved into
that side of the souls community doing
I've been waiting for an excuse to shut
them out for ages you can watch these
dreamers for hours on end and never get
bored because it's so exciting watching
them break the game in such controlled
ways and you never know when they're
about to break a new world record so
it's really exciting
and speaking of breaking records hitting
new milestones we hit a million
subscribers after the last video at the
end of the souls saga no less like that
feels really neat to me so thank you so
much for being here
I remember when I started and I couldn't
even comprehend 500 people like try to
do that you can't imagine 500 individual
people with all their complexities like
you just can't do it
I don't think and I don't think you can
truly conceptualize what that amount of
people means let alone a million I did
this notepad thing I so reckful do once
just to help me visualize what a million
looked like but it just made things
worse
but you know yes a million is an
insanely striking number and you get a
thrill when you see it on your channel
page for the first time for sure but
then the next day it hits you a little
less and then the next day it hits you a
little bit less than that and then the
next day it's just normal you know like
every other milestone you hit in life no
matter what it is I don't think you can
do YouTube or anything really just for
the milestones or the money you make it
just doesn't fulfill you it's not really
enough in my opinion so what's really
grounded me as I continue doing stuff on
this channel is thinking about the
individual behind the screen and you can
get really caught up in the statistics
but I think that the statistics that
really represents the individual like
you behind the screen or me watching a
youtube video is one stat called viewer
retention and it's basically how long
the average viewer will watch your video
and this is what I care about I care
that 60 to 70 percent of you guys stay
until the very end of the video and from
what I hear those are pretty good stats
because more than subscribers I care
that you get excited when you see one of
my videos uploaded I care that you don't
feel like quitting the video halfway
through I care that you might walk away
from the video and enjoy the Seoul
series that tiny bit more because that's
a feeling I can grasp and empathize with
and it matters way more than a million
subscribers does in my opinion because
celebrating a million sort of devalues
the individual behind the screen and the
individual is what matters right
I could go on for a long time I could
talk about how great it's been to be a
part of this community and what it's
like sharing how amazing these games are
like I could really go into depth on
that but you guys know you guys can
empathize with that feeling I'm sure
because you know how great these games
are and what it's like to share it with
other people maybe through this YouTube
channel or maybe people you know in real
life or maybe people you talk to online
people you do co-op with you understand
what it's like and I just want to thank
you for being a part of that for me so
it reads around the corner and honestly
I feel like for leaks
this year our own software might be
better than what they could possibly
announce just look at this so I'm pretty
sure they'll announce something at e3
that will be relevant to us and to the
channel because while they have said
that they aren't working on anymore
Souls like titles I like blood-borne or
Dark Souls they said they are working on
something that will be interesting to
the Souls audience so in my opinion I
feel like they won't stray too far from
the souls like sort of a genre they've
created for themselves and you can't
really take everything they say about
the future from software like face value
you can't take it without a grain of
salt because remember just before they
announced blood-borne Miyazaki said he
wanted to work on something happier and
light-hearted and a more warmer universe
and then he announced blood-borne this
gory gruesome title about werewolves and
aliens so you never really know what
they're planning but I'm sure it will be
interesting to some of us so as always
thank you for watching and I'll see you
next time
you
[Music]